hey dr. Berg here in this video we're
going to talk about the digestive system
now the purpose of the digestive system
is to take the food that you eat break
it down into very small particles and
extract nutrients from it to allow you
to convert food to body tissues like
hair nails skin heart liver lungs all
the body parts and it's really simple
there's all there's like five different
parts of the digestive system you have
the liver stomach gall bladder pancreas
and intestine now the purpose of the
liver is to help make digestive juices
that's one of the purposes that's stored
in the gall bladder
so the gall bladder is a reservoir or a
holding tank for the digestive juices
that come out of the liver the purpose
of the stomach is to produce acid to
break down proteins and this strength of
that stomach acid is so powerful so
acidic it can dissolve a razorblade so
we need to digest the protein here and
then it goes right into the right into
this part of the small intestine where
it's activated by this digestive juice
from the gall bladder comes out that's
called bile B I le not bow-like waste
but bile and that the purpose of the
bile is to break down fats and to
extract nutrients from the fats like
vitamin A E K and D those are called fat
soluble vitamins you have a water
soluble but you also effects I have a
vitamin so you're going to find vitamin
A D and K in fatty foods okay
now right here the pancreas produces a
lot of different enzymes to digest
carbohydrates proteins and fats as well
it also makes certain hormones and then
all this bacteria down here give like a
over a hundred trillion bacteria that
are helping you break down food even
further and they have little hairs in
the small intestine like little roots
that absorb all the nutrients like a
root in a plant pulls it in and it goes
right into the liver and it goes into
the cells okay so that would be the
summary of the five areas of digestion
so the gallbladder right here is does
not produce anything it actually holds
something
it holds bile and what happens is it
fills up with bowel when you eat and
then it squishes and it contracts that
vile that goes down these little tubes
they're called bile ducts now if there's
a problem with not enough bile you will
start developing stones like this and so
now the bile can't be released because
it gets all plugged up and then they
have to remove it now when that thing
swells up and it gets too big it pushes
on a nerve that goes all up to the right
shoulder and the neck and can cause all
sorts of issues we'll get into that in a
second but a normal gallbladder should
be free of golf stones and it should be
able to push the bile through this duct
right here okay let's talk about bile
what is bile bile B il e is the
detergent that dissolves the grease or
the oil from your foods the fats and
that includes even fat's in vegetables
as well so you have vitamin A D and K
and E that it extracts from the food so
here's what happens I'm just going to do
a little demonstration here if my
cameraman could hold this for a second
I'm going to open this thing up here and
we're going to take this dishwashing
liquid which is detergent and pour it
into the oil okay so we're just going to
pour that in there and we're going to
just give this back right here and
what's happening now is this detergent
is breaking down the oil I'm going to
make sure this should shake sealed
pretty good because I'm going to start
to shake this here and start to dissolve
it okay so let's look the gallbladder
desk with fats look at what happens it's
breaking down the fats into small little
particles so we go from fat to fatty
acids fatty acids are small particles of
the fat and this is exactly what bile
does to that fat that you eat it breaks
it down so you
can use it and extracts the nutrients
vitamin A D and K now the thing that you
need to realize is that it also acts as
a detox er so if there's anything toxic
in the liver or there's dust in the body
or particles that you breathe in or
preservatives or whatever it will go to
the liver and come out through that mile
so bile is important in the
detoxification of chemicals and toxins
so each year 20 million people are
diagnosed with gall bladder problems and
over half that's 10 million people have
their gallbladders removed so when the
gall bladder is removed or it's
dysfunctional that doesn't mean the
problem is gone that means you're never
going to have enough file to be able to
help you digest here's some common
symptoms that occur with a bile is
deficiency number one bloating because
you don't have anything to digest
everything's going to be because bile is
a lubricant everything's going to be
constipated as well so you have
constipation burping belching those are
the top 3 right shoulder pain why
because when that thing enlarges it's
going to push a nerve called the phrenic
nerve that goes all the way up to right
through here up into your neck and even
in your scapula back here right back in
the back part right there so anything on
the right side it could be underneath
the right ribcage heaviness on the right
side on the upper part of your body and
right side of the neck and of course
headaches nauseated
that's why females when they will have a
baby and all that's different pressure
that puts up in the gall bladder they're
going to become nauseated headaches or
migraines 98% of all headaches are
related to the gallbladder or lacking a
bile now if you have a headache and you
were to press right on this one point
over here where the gall bladders and
give it some relief and allow it to
drain the headache' probably would be
relieved now we also have not satisfied
when you eat if there's not enough bile
you're not going to feel satisfied
you're going to feel like you're missing
something because you're not pulling the
nutrients from
the fats or the foods so you're always
going to be missing and you're going to
want to keep eating also you're going to
crave fried foods or you need a little
bit of sweet after you eat because the
bile is very essential in regulating the
blood sugars because if you're pulling
nutrients out you're stabilizing the
blood sugars and then itchy skin itchy
eyes hives that would be another symptom
of gallbladder problems and also
sneezing it's another one now bile is
made out of cholesterol now I know
people have this thing about cholesterol
it's bad and everything but here's the
facts and cholesterol 75 percent of the
cholesterol in your body right now is
made by your own body it makes it
surrounds the raw material that build
the membranes of all your cells in your
body it's raw material to build all the
sex hormones in your body including
cortisol which is for an
anti-inflammatory your lens of your eye
the retina it's used to balance out
estrogen and a female so it's very very
necessary to regulate hormones to help
heal the tissue especially under stress
and without enough cholesterol there's a
lot of other symptoms because your body
will start to basically cannibalize
parts of your tissue that have the
cholesterol to use that back so the
thing is its cholesterol is not a bad
thing but it excesses it can be a bad
thing but as long as you're eating
enough greens and vegetables you're safe
because all that vegetable will flush
out any type of buildup of cholesterol
I'm not saying eat huge steaks and all
this fat and bacon grease but I'm not
opposed to it if you consume the amount
of vegetables to clean out the liver
there's nothing wrong with some fatty
foods as long as your your liver is
healthy okay but the point is that when
you mix all the breads pasta cereal
breaded meats and all that cooked fried
food and you have this little side salad
that's not going to be enough to get the
liver so that so that's why you have a
problem with cholesterol and also
carbohydrates like refined sure
bread and pasta and carbs convert into
cholesterol as well all right
so those are some common symptoms and if
you don't have the bile you won't be
able to multi-on break down the
cholesterol and it can build up in the
body as well now because the vitamins
the fat side vitamins are associated
with bile problems if you don't have
enough file you become deficient in
vitamin A and that's when the vision
becomes a problem at night night
blindness and dry skin vitamin A is for
the skin and the eye so you get dry
cornea or eye dry eyes and then you get
a lot of other skin problems with
vitamin A accutane is a type of vitamin
A so what does that use for acne skin
problems
warts cornea issues little growths of
that little deposit on your eyes so
vitamin A is very important but it's not
necessarily what you eat that makes you
healthy it's what you digest without
that bile which I find a lot of people
don't have in a file
you can't extract the vitamin A to get
the relief or the benefits from vitamin
A vitamin A supports all the mucous
membranes in your sinuses so when you
start digesting and getting vitamin A
your sinuses clear up as well vitamin D
is a fat sack of vitamin so you can get
winter blues depression that time like
in the winter bone health by the mini is
muscle tissues without vitamin E the
heart has to work really hard because
it's not going to be able to retain the
oxygen to the heart so you're going to
lose endurance so you go up an incline
and you get out of breath very easily
that's because vitamin E is a fat
soluble vitamin so the heart and muscles
are can need that vitamin A the retina
retinal degeneration occurs in the
absence of vitamin E because vitamin E
is a great healer for certain tissues
and the pituitary runs on vitamin E as
well so during menopause because you
lose the ovaries the requirement of
vitamin E goes up by a hundred 100 X
because the pituitary is not working
like it did before
in the butt so that's just another thing
after
menopause you see a lot of women that
just dry out but you can't absorb
vitamin E if you don't have the bile all
right then we have items' and k you need
that for the bone health and in a
deficiency you'll have bleeding bloody
noses so those are some of the symptoms
of a bile deficiency okay so now let's
talk about the causes of a problem with
the gall bladder in a bile issue number
one junk food that would include breads
pasta cereal crackers biscuits waffles
pancakes all those wonderful things
fatty foods why because too much fat can
clog up that whole system what can a
great the gallbladder are nuts when you
start eating a lot of nuts --is you
start eating healthy and you start
loading yourself up with nuts or peanut
butter and you start having right
shoulder pain that's because it's
aggravating the bile ducts which is
going right up to the right shoulder
okay sugar will do it we talked about
grains soy protein isolates yeah that
there's been no it's been known that it
can create liver tumors so it's very
irritating to the liver now where do you
find soy protein isolates a lot of
vegetarian patties that they have at the
store vegetarian food it's also in a lot
of diet foods all those prepackaged
foods read the label a lot of protein
powders have soy protein excellence as a
cheap protein but it's very hard on the
gallbladder in the liver
I had a gal come in she did a diet down
the street and they gave her this
protein powder and it was just soy
protein chocolate flavored soy protein
isolate
she started burping for an entire year
and no one knew what it was it's just
basically destroyed her gallbladder she
couldn't stop burping and that's why she
came to see me cook protein too much
heavy cooked protein because it you're
when you eat cooked protein there's no
enzymes enzymes are destroyed with the
heat and it drew acid these guys have to
work harder even when you eat roasted
peanuts it will make the pancreas
enlarge because it has to produce more
enzymes to digest that roasted nut I'm
not saying not that don't worry about
cutting that out if you're eating good
overall you don't worry about it
but if you're just eating all cooked
foods that
be very bad for the liver and then we
have alcohol of course that's a given
and then estrogen estrogen will
constrict this duct and cause problems
with the bile as well that's one of the
side effects and that would be birth
control pills hormone replacement
therapy becoming pregnant that spikes
the estrogen that time of the month when
you spikes the estrogen or actually
ovulation a fibroid can cause too much
estrogen doing too many soy products
will cause a lot of estrogen problems so
estrogen can definitely create a issue
with that and also cause headaches
cortisol cortisol is connected in the
recycling process of bile so over a
period of time when you get really
stressed out over many many years it
will deplete your bile and cause
digestive problems so you start bloating
like you eat something you feel like
you're pregnant and then at night you're
more bloated in during the morning it's
actually flattens because there's less
stress okay so there's a connection
between stress and digestion and then
lack of the right foods if you're not
eating enough vegetables you're going to
end up with a problem with this because
this the vegetables clean this thing out
there's some interesting points if you
find that you sleep on your left side
and it's more comfortable than the right
side I'm sorry if you sleep on the right
side and it's more comfortable than the
left side chances are this there's a
problem with the liver in the
gallbladder because the hearts over here
and so if you sleep on your left side
down this thing is too heavy it's going
to compress and push like a vise on the
heart and it's going to be hard to
breathe so the best position to sleep
with a gall bladder on your right side
okay also the thyroid works through the
liver in order eighty percent of the
thyroid is converted to an active form
of thyroid hormone in the liver so if
this is blocked up down here you may
find that the thyroid might not work as
well and also with a problem with this
you're going to have you're going to
start building up estrogen and that
indirectly decreases testosterone and
that's why you see a lot of men that
start out getting breast tissue you're
going to breast
answer they're losing their chest hair
all these problems with estrogen and
progesterone so there's one of the
products that I use is called gall
bladder formula and I created it not
just to give the person some bile salts
but I put several things in there
because there's a lot of different
issues that can occur with with the gall
bladder number one it could be too thick
I could mean that your stomach is not
acid enough to release your own bile so
I put Petain how to chloride in there as
well
I put beets to thin the bile there's
bile salts in here to give you bio so
you can start recycling it there's
Spanish black radish that's good for the
liver as well and that thins the bile to
out allow it to work better so it's not
so congested
there's stone root and that is known to
actually dissolve stones and there's an
enzyme that the stomach needs to in
their slippery elm bark to help
lubricate this whole process now I'm
just letting you know that I'm not
saying that this is going to replace or
cure your gall bladder all I'm saying is
this is what I use to support a healthy
gall bladder function so if you need
some you might want to try some take one
before a meal every time you eat a large
meal and because it's not a drug it
works kind of slowly and you're going to
find that you're going to digest better
and your stomach's not going to be so
bloated so if you need it go ahead and
try it I hope you enjoyed the video I'll
see you in the next video